I am a data scientist at Skyscanner
as of this week but for the last five
years I was working at the University of
Cambridge on a research projects related
to smartphones so I'm going to be
talking a little bit about that so
assumptions for this talk that you've
used Python before that you've run into
machine learning problems and that you
have a smartphone which I'm guessing for
this audience maybe a lot of you have
more than one so the cool thing
obviously about smartphones is that they
have sensors in them and every time that
another smartphone is released they
always advertise them with more sensors
inside of them and there's an
interesting pattern in in the research
field which is that every time a new
device comes out with a new sensor in it
you know within a few months
researchers are publishing papers
showing what sort of behaviors you can
learn about the smartphone owner based
on that so just to give you some
examples obviously GPS is in all our
phones now to support mapping but it's
also been used heavily to track people's
mobility patterns just like the
orangutangs in the previous talk but
also things that we wouldn't maybe
consider as sensors like the microphone
and Bluetooth have been used to study
how we behave so I think there's a
famous project out of MIT that was
looking at Bluetooth in the phone and
detecting other Bluetooth sensors as a
way of getting a signal of of
collocation of two people hanging out
with each other so I'm gonna be talking
about the accelerometer and when I first
started with this research I was told a
story and I'm gonna tell you that story
I don't know if it's true but let's
pretend it's true so so the way it goes
is that originally accelerometers were
put into smartphones so that they could
support landscape mode and so that your
phone would be able to detect when you
move your phone from this position to
that position so that it could reset the
the interface of course it didn't take
very long to figure out
if you're carrying an accelerometer in
your pocket all the time or in your bag
then you can use that same data to
figure out a lot about how you're
behaving in your everyday life so in
this talk I'm just going to basically
run you through maybe what was about
four hours worth of work
over the last couple of days so
collecting some data taking a peek at
the raw data then putting it all
together and building a classifier to
figure out what I'm doing
based on just raw accelerometer data and
everything is is online here including
the talk the Android app and and all the
Python stuff so let's dive in the way I
started was I built a very simple
Android app and from a user perspective
this is the way it looks what I have to
do is select an activity that I'm doing
and click start sensing and the app
would begin collecting accelerometer
data and then when I'm done I just click
stop so that's the interaction behind
creating my data set under the hood
Android if you're writing a native
Android is in Java and the paradigm is
that the app is going to register a
listener with the operating system so
it's going to say I want to register
with the sensor which is in this case is
the accelerometer so it's basically just
saying to the device give me some
accelerometer data at this rate sensor
delay game so the rate doesn't really
matter for this talk but game is quite a
quite a I guess a fine-grained way of
collecting accelerometer data maybe it's
called game because you think of playing
games on your phone and when I click the
start button so it registers says start
giving me data when I click the stop
button it says ok I'm done stop giving
me data and all my app was doing is it
was writing that data into CSV files
that I could just then pull straight off
the device so super hacky don't do it
don't code review
my ab but let's run right into the data
so an accelerometer is a very simple
sensor that captures acceleration in in
three dimensions so you can think of
your phone is having maybe an x axis y
axis and the z axis going this way and
so what the accelerometer is doing is
feeling how much acceleration is it's
experiencing along these three
dimensions so you can look at the data
as three time series where you have the
x y&z and so what does that look like in
practice well the first activity I had
was just standing and these are the
three axes and pop quiz why is this one
hanging out around 9.6 gravity so the
device isn't moving but it's still
feeling the acceleration of gravity
which is constant in this case it was on
the z axis so let's go around to other
activities this is me walking running
some walking some laps in my back garden
running and running actually even though
I have a twisted ankle right now I was
managing to to max out the sensor in
this particular device stairs a little
bit fake I just had one stair and I was
going up and down it and then this is me
coming in to London so I was on the
Metropolitan line somewhere between I
think Wembley Park and Finchley Road and
and to be honest it was in the morning
so I don't remember exactly what was
happening but but this is the Train so
one of the key things about this is that
you know I've labeled this x y&z but you
know for all you know there could be a
bug in my code and the axes could have
been mislabeled and that's a very
important thing about this kind of data
is that if you were collecting it in in
from some sort of app it's kind of easy
to get people to maybe label their
activity sometimes
it's very difficult to get them to tell
you precisely how their phone is
oriented so there's been some research
studies where they they are very
prescriptive they say we're gonna need
you to collect data but then put the
phone in here or put the phone there and
you know it really takes things away
from from how they work in practice a
little bit so we know we need to start
thinking about how can we work with this
data and and factor out the orientation
aspect so one of the ways that this is
done is by taking all these three axes
and combining them into one and that's
what's known as the magnitude vector and
so basically you're just taking the
let's see if I can get this right and
one go the square root of the sum of
squares of the of each axis so maybe I
got that wrong but let me show you what
it looks like in practice if I made the
magnitude vector of each oh it's clipped
at the top so this is standing walking
running stairs and on that morning
commute train and now you can even start
seeing visually that there is a
difference in in the different kinds of
activities and in particular the one
that stood out for me is that standing
data looked quite noisy at first but
once we get the magnitude vector its we
can see that it's quite flat there's not
that much going on so what can we do
with this data well there are three
things and I'm going to focus on one but
I'll quickly mention the other two the
first one is step counting so I even
have I have it somewhere it'll probably
come ahead so you can just count how
many steps is a person taking that's
really an exercise in figuring out where
steps happen in the data and maybe even
figuring out that the person is taking
steps in the first place and so there's
a there's a great paper that was
published a few years ago about that
the second one is about profiling people
and I can tell you a little story about
this which is that a number of years ago
we in Cambridge released an app
that was collecting this accelerometer
data and it wasn't asking people what
they're doing but it was collecting that
data and it instead it was asking people
how they feel and so what we get
once we fold that data on top of each
other aggregated is a little signal like
this so one row of this is a person a
person's typical day and brighter colors
means that they're being more active
darker colors means they're being less
active and so you can imagine that as
being your unique signature of how you
live your daily life and the reason why
there are three groups is because we ran
these profiles through a clustering
algorithm to say what sort of different
activities are in the data and we had
people who are really active all the way
to people who don't seem to be moving at
all so the interesting thing here is
that like I said the app was asking
people how they feel and what we found
is there was a nice correlation between
people who tend to feel more positive
throughout their day and are happier
were also up here and the weird thing
about that was obviously while I was
doing all this analysis I was very
sedentary so I was maybe a little bit
down there but like I said the focus of
this talk is looking more at activity
classification so a great example of
that is the google fit app which does do
the step counting bit which I was
looking for earlier but also is
reporting you know 15 minutes of walking
it automatically detects cycling as well
and so what I want to give you in the
next few slides is an intuition of how
this works under the hood so from a top
level we have these time series and what
we need to do is get these time series
into some kind of manageable way that we
can train a classifier then we can train
a classifier we can predict some
activities and we can we can put it into
an app we can use it for other
quantified self experiments and these
sort of things so there's a very related
problem to this which is the problem of
detecting entities in
images so I don't know if many of you
have come across this before but this
was the very first Google Image result
for entity detection and essentially you
can imagine an algorithm that some kind
of machine learning algorithm that will
tell you yes there's an entity in this
or no there's no entity in this and so
given a big picture what you typically
do is you take a square and you say is
there an entity in this Square and the
algorithm says no so then you just move
the square over a little bit and say is
there an entity there no and this is
called a sliding window problem a
sliding window approach and so you take
that that square you move it across your
whole image you move it maybe using
whatever method you want and at a
certain point it'll say oh yes there's
an entity here and yes there's an entity
here and you know basically after
querying your machine learning algorithm
you know hundreds of times you will have
found the four beetles so we're doing a
very similar thing but with time series
data so we can define a window and now
we're gonna walk across that window and
say what's going on here
what's going on here what's going on
here and so in typical scenarios that
time window will be maybe five seconds
or ten seconds but it depends on your
application but interestingly we don't
just use that as a way of you know
testing the algorithm we also use it as
a way of extracting features to train
the algorithm so what do I mean by that
I mean that we take this data the time
series data and for each window we're
going to extract a number of descriptive
statistics or features so again there's
a really good paper that explains this
much better than then then I could in in
all this detail but really what they do
is they say that for each of these
windows there's a number of different
characteristics that we can extract from
and they talked about a whole family
maybe five different categories of these
of these characteristics but you know
you can take these sort
three so in this window what are some
statistical characteristics like the
average the minimum the maximum the
standard deviation what are some
characteristics of the time series like
the jitter which I'll get to and or you
know you can go on and and you know
dream up as many features as you want so
I'll look at to that that I implemented
the first one is measuring like I said
jitter in the in D in the signal and
really all that's doing is it's looking
at the difference between the previous
measurement and the current measurement
so if we go back to our example you can
say oh look if there's you know this
reading was down here the next reading
is up here and the next reading is down
here the next reading is up there that's
high jitter otherwise if you know you
have a reading here and then up there
and then down here and then up there
that's very low jitter so that's one
thing that we could look at the second
thing is maybe more is somewhat similar
you could look at the what's called a
mean crossing rate and I'll give you two
examples that that highlight this so
imagine a signal that is very high and
stable and then it drops and then it's
very low and stable so your your mean is
somewhere in the middle of that and by
being very high and then dropping and
then being very low it's crossed the
mean once so this type of time series
has a very low mean crossing rate on the
other hand imagine a signal that goes
like this
right and it's doing that very fast so
it's got maybe even some high jitter
characteristics so again the mean of
that signal is somewhere in the middle
but since it's been going up and down
and up and down and up and down it's got
a very high mean crossing rate so these
are two features that I implemented
myself but the nice thing obviously
about Python is that there's loads of
features and loads of libraries that
implement things that are maybe even a
bit more complex to implement so the two
that that I was looking at were stats
models and scifi stats
Sify stats has
skew and kurtosis again I wouldn't even
be able to write the math for that just
off the top of my head and stats models
has cool things like the auto
correlation and the auto covariance so
really all I was doing is taking all
these features and producing a list and
what that means is that for every single
window in my data I'm looking at what
are the features of the x axis y axis
and the magnitude vector then I'm moving
the window over what other features
there and I'm moving my window over and
to make a long story short I'm just
creating a nice data frame where I say I
know what's going on here because I've
labeled it I've said I'm walking here
and here's a list of representing all
the features of the x axis first then
the y axis and the z axis then the
magnitude vector so once we're there now
things you know thankfully for for
Python and scikit-learn
get pretty easy right so we have the
data in a nice format and all we all we
have to do is just load it into
scikit-learn and in this case what I
wanted to do was actually see how the
weather I can predict what activity I'm
doing and whether I can predict what
actually I'm doing better than some kind
of dumb baseline so the dumb baseline is
what in scikit-learn is called the dummy
classifier and I'm sure some of you have
run into it before and all that is doing
by default is it's as it says in
documentation generating predictions by
respecting the training sets class
distribution so what that means if I
have five classes they're uniformly
distributed there's same amount of data
for each class then I'd expect by
picking a class at random I'd expect to
be about 20 percent accurate overall and
what what I'd hope is for the random
forests to be which uses the data to do
a little bit better than that
so all I do is I repeat this experiment
times and I split the data set into 60%
that is going to be used to train the
algorithm 40% that is going to be used
to test it and then I run it through
these both the both of these classifiers
so the random forest and the baseline
and I score them at the default scoring
I think is accuracy so the gist behind
that is if we predict walking and it is
walking then it's plus 1 if we predict
running and it's walking then that's a
zero so run through the 10 experiments
and average them and we do find that the
baseline is about 20% it's a little bit
higher but the random forest goes all
the way up to 98% which is a very
impressive number to report but of
course there's a number of limitations
here so here's that was basically
Thursday night I hacked together the app
and at about 1:00 a.m. I started running
around and last night after work I did
the the feature stuff and the
experiments so really what you've seen
today is a very simple explanation of
this problem and especially it's a very
simplified version of this problem
because it's not super realistic so
there there are a number of other things
that can make this problem a lot more
complicated but the main thing that I
wanted to highlight was the method that
I use to train these algorithms so what
things can make this more complicated
this is along the entire pipeline
starting from collecting the data so if
you are going to build an app that is
collecting accelerometer data the app
that I made as soon as you press the
home button
it stops collecting data so if you don't
have this app active on the front it
just doesn't collect any any data so
there's ways of on Android on iOS it's a
whole different story on Android of
collecting this data in the background
but then
you need to start considering about how
frequently you're collecting the data
what sampling rate you're using should
you stop sensing when you're not
detecting any activity because
ultimately if you are just collecting
data all the time you can write an app
that does this and it'll it'll burn
through the battery within a few hours
and people will uninstall your app and
write you angry emails the real data is
certainly Messier this example just me
just one phone just one sensor and there
are differences across devices and in
particular with the data from the public
apps that we were using we had to
denoise it a lot there were even some
instances of things that we saw that
were impossibly high amounts of
acceleration as if they were you know
shooting up to the moon or something and
I'm assuming that's that no one in the
space station right now had my app
installed so when it came to features
what you saw today was me just throwing
everything at the problem which is
sometimes nice but there are many other
different kinds of features that you
could use and and finally the most
probably the most important thing is
that the machine learning problem that I
showed you is really about detecting one
of five activities but there are many
more different things that you can do so
for example you could turn it into a
binary classification problem and say is
the person walking right now and that's
actually probably more realistic because
you can't train for all of the
activities that are possible so it's
more likely that you will train a model
on one activity that you want to
identify and train it against data where
you just know that it's not that
activity and finally again as a
consequence of being just one person the
data I showed you was trained on me and
then test it on me and in practice
you're going to be collect
there are some images online of famous
tech companies that strap phones to
their employees and ask them to to
perform activities like cycle and and
walk and they use that as their training
data but then they're going to be trying
to predict other people so that makes
things much more complicated and one way
that you can get around that is by as
you're collecting data from those other
people you use that to tailor your model
and make personalized prediction so can
identify that I am walking versus other
people so just to wrap up quick hack
over the last two nights all the way
from collecting accelerometer data to
classifying it and what I hope to have
shown you is that this is actually
easier to hack at than what I originally
thought when I was approaching this
problem and really what this does is is
starting to open up a lot of research
going towards a lot of new mobile
applications that are going to be using
these kind of techniques on different
kinds of sensor data in order to make
the user experience better so just as an
example one of the last projects that I
was working on in Cambridge was related
to smoking cessation and what we wanted
to do was detect when people are most
likely to smoke so we had them telling
us when they were smoking and then we
used similar techniques in this case it
wasn't with accelerometer data but it
was with location data to make
inferences about the risk that they are
for smoking and particular times and
places and so forth and when the
algorithm detected that risk
they were fired off some nice cognitive
behavioral therapy that would help to
keep them motivated to to keep up with
their quit attempts so like I said
everything is online happy for you to
report in any bugs to me or take this
code and do whatever you want with it
and with that thank you very much happy
to take any questions
sorry the size of the window is in my
experiences it's a heuristic that you
have to play with so the way that I
decided when I was doing the research
was I asked other researchers what
windows they use and the answers came
back usually like on the 5 to 20 second
side but in practice I think it relates
to whatever high level goal you have in
your app yeah yeah yeah yeah I was
starting to have a stab at this and it's
you know well the approach that I was
using was trying to throw different
clustering algorithms at it the problem
is that when you know when you're
dealing with a data set from the public
you can't validate it you can just say
this is something that I've never seen
before and I'm not sure where it is and
when you're dealing with a data set that
you made it's too simplistic right so
what we found in in the data from the
public was that even certain activities
that we had people reporting there was a
huge variability in those activities so
the way that I walk versus maybe the way
my grandmother walks or something not
that any grandmother's were probably
using my app but but so so a very
challenging problem and the main
challenge behind it is that so many
activities from a feature perspective
it's different it's very difficult to
say that this is a completely new
activity versus this is a variant of an
activity that I've seen before
final comment on that one of the ways
that we were also looking at this was by
watches and collecting data from from
two devices from the same person at the
same time and looking at variability
there and that again highlighted that
the same activity can produce very
different data so you know just another
challenge yeah yeah yeah I guess so I I
guess just oh yes that's true there you
go you would you'd have canceled that
one out I never really thought too much
about the skydiving scenario to be
honest yeah yep
binary feature very unlikely prior
probably yes
sorry can you say
yeah the initial I probably should have
mentioned this like my first line of
exploration was into time series
modeling and and this is me having never
done any smartphone machine learning
stuff and thinking Oh XOR murders
produce time series data so let me look
at time series modeling and you know a
lot of time series forecasting is about
forecasting maybe even the shape of the
time series and that's not so relevant
to doing solving these kind of problems
where the actual shape of the exo-armor
time series is not as important as the
features of that shape all right I hope
that kind of that's one thing that I
messed up on but I could probably think
of a lot more
yep
when you trade them all
actually I initially with
yeah yeah so yeah that's a very good
point this is a toy example where I
manually balanced all the data and my
original data set maybe it's the one
that's on github does have more standing
than then walking and certainly I think
in the end I had to prune it because I
ran the least I pruned it down to I
pruned all the other data down to as
much running as I had yeah in practice I
think you would probably be looking at a
one versus all type of problem so even
in those problems you have very
unbalanced data what was your second
question
yeah yeah that's true I haven't i'm
completely new to that I'm just starting
to hack with it and I know there are
some researchers where who are looking
at it and they're even looking at it
from the point of view of running the LS
TM on the device itself which has some
cool like privacy preserving aspects
because then you're just maybe
transmitting the output of that but
short answer no I haven't yet
yeah yeah that's a good point I haven't
looked at that No
maybe I'll try it why don't they see
things that's a that's a very good point
and I probably should have mentioned it
in my final thoughts layering in other
sensors is as far as I've been able to
see the one of the most widely practiced
ways of sensing with more energy
efficiency and then also squeezing a bit
more out of your data
I left the dryer out just to keep this
simple
but a very neat example of this in
practice is treating your sensor
sampling kind of like kind of like TCP
on the web where you sample from the
sensor and if you don't really or you
sample from a family of sensors like
location and accelerometer
and then if you don't detect a change in
one sensor you turn off the other ones
right so oh we're still in the same
place oh we're still in the same place
so or oh we're in a very different place
let's ramp up how much activity were
sensing maybe Neil has left his house
and it started walking
so those a lot of those systems are
still very heuristic based like the
example I just gave but yeah I haven't
really seen in those kind of models in
in practice but I have a feeling
probably the google fit app does some of
that cool stuff yeah
no I haven't and I think by having the
three axes it made my results more
impressive but because in practice maybe
what was happening in my data mostly on
the x-axis would be distributed across
the three axes in in a larger more
realistic data set but I would class
that under sort of broader exercise in
in feature engineering and you know some
of the features that I described today
you could probably junk because they're
probably highly correlated with each
other so that's the cool thing about
random forests is that you can inspect
that and and then throw them away or or
think about adding in some more
hold on thank you very much